it's great to welcome to the program
today Ellen rupal she'll who is a
correspondent for the Atlantic also
author of the job work and its future in
a time of radical change
Ellen it's so great to have you on
thanks for having me David it's so to
begin with we've been talking sort of
piecemeal for many years about
technological automation the
possibilities of universal basic income
examining the areas of our
socio-economic system that are working
well in the areas that that are not
working so well but it seems that often
missing from this conversation is the
reality that at a certain point humans
are going to kind of need to re-examine
the relationship to work and the idea of
a sort of 40-hour full-time job as the
sole path towards other than independent
wealth sustaining oneself in the world
can you talk a little bit about sort of
the big picture of the change that you
see happening in terms of humans and
their relationship to work David you put
that beautifully okay and what you just
described is precisely why I wrote this
book my concern going in here was that
we were in something like a denial
national denial about how things were
changing economically socially on all
different kind of all different levels
and what we were doing was desperately
trying to hang on to jobs that were no
longer salient in the current economy
right jobs that that would were being
outsourced jobs increasingly that are
being automated and we weren't really
coming to grips with the fact that jobs
per se might be on the way out okay
now historically jobs are kind of a new
idea I mean it's hard to imagine this
about before about 1900 or so most
people didn't really have jobs right
most Americans worked in agriculture
they either
on their land or worked on farms many
also have trades and were entrepreneurs
of a sort so the whole notion of having
a job was not really necessarily a
positive thing as you can imagine
there's an agricultural community if you
had a job that means you would be
holding to a landowner you were say a
farmhand that was your job but what you
really aspired to have was your own land
and be something of an entrepreneur so
the whole notion of having a job has
really only since the late Industrial
Revolution and you know going forward
into our current century obviously that
21st century has held such cachet and
we're hanging onto this idea that we all
need to be working for someone else
right and we need to be employed in a
certain kind of way and all this to me
seems a little nostalgic and a little a
historical because in fact that's not
the way it's always been
and going forward you know that may not
be the way it's going to be and we need
to come to grips with that and
understand what steps we need to take to
ensure that everyone is able to afford
to live is able to make a living and
also is able to find a sense of purpose
and meaning in their work so you talked
about the discussion of bringing jobs
back that don't exist anymore
and this has become extraordinarily
politicized and what I've pointed out is
that if you have two presidential
candidates for example and they argue
about who is going to bring back for
example manufacturing jobs from Asia or
whatever the discussion may be as soon
as one of them says the truth which is a
lot of those jobs just don't exist
anymore their opponent says that's a
defeatist attitude and that's exactly
why you should vote for me instead of my
opponent so how can we break through
that and actually start to think about
what we're going to do in reality
instead of fantasizing about bringing
jobs back that don't exist when there's
no political incentive to do it based on
how our election system works
right again a very good point um you
know jobs many jobs can go anywhere you
know they don't really have a
natural-born home you know we think that
they do a lot of politicians say that
they do but they actually don't right
they can go anywhere and not just
factory jobs but white-collar jobs
knowledge jobs coding jobs for example
this is a very vaunted category of jobs
we are with there's a lot of talk about
having former factory workers or coal
miners learn coding but that's a
temporary fix at best because the
ability to code is an international one
there are people all over the world who
are fully capable of doing it it's not
necessarily an American job right so the
notion that we can keep jobs of all
sorts in the United States in the
digital age is pretty naive and you're
absolutely right that when political
candidates talk straight on this on this
point they often lose traction but I
think I traveled the United States to do
this book and in areas for example the
Rust Belt or in Kentucky in the mining
in areas of Kentucky the the residents
are actually quite aware of this you
know people are not stupid
they know what's going on
so speaking the truth on this I think is
getting to be going to be more and more
accepted because people are
understanding it so even though you know
we're sometimes told for example the
marine effort right where a Chinese
manufacturer was setting up in Ohio
outside of Dayton in a former GM plant I
don't know if you were to call that ones
in the recent news and in fact guess
what they're not really going to do
manufacturing there there they pulled
back dramatically on the number of hires
they're going to make in Ohio right so
this is you know a more most recent case
of this
it's of course people there now
understand that this is not something
that's going to have any durability over
the long term and I think increasingly
politicians who speak this truth will be
accepted what else in your mind counts
as a temporary solution and I guess what
I'm what I'm interested in hearing about
a little bit is universal basic income
which I've been studying for a very long
time and while I see it heavily
supported by lots of progressive
economists most of them are saying I
support it as a step based on where we
are right now but it's not really a
long-term solution to the problems that
we're going to have yeah universal basic
income is is something that I was thrown
about quite a bit recently Silicon
Valley Valley got on board with that of
course because they in recent years have
started to get to admit that they are on
unemployment and they were concerned
about that so the whole idea of you bei
and versatile basic income was very
tantalizing to people in Silicon Valley
I described it in the book as something
that should be used as a spice now how
does a main course okay so there are
examples for example in Canada in the
1970s this basic income was applied to a
community in Canada and it was very very
helpful okay so it was an impoverished
community or poor community and they
applied it selectively over a short term
a few years and it did lift people out
of poverty it gave them the opportunity
to become more entrepreneurial for
example in one case I interviewed some
of the people who had actually been
living there in the 1970s so for example
one guy was able to buy a truck right
and and able to be much more effective
in his agricultural efforts because he'd
had this income boost
young men were able to stay in high
school and graduate from high school
young women or young mothers were able
to stay home with their weather infants
these were all positive things and so I
believe a universal basic income or a
basic income guarantee as it's sometimes
called taking out the word univer
whistle can be very helpful applied
selectively but of course I don't think
anyone believes it's a long-term
solution nationally it's extremely
expensive highly controversial and it
doesn't solve things over the long term
when we think about the class impact of
what's coming there are is one point of
view which says ok technological
unemployment or automation related
unemployment is going to
disproportionately affect people who are
already economically disadvantaged way
more than people who are upper middle
class and higher however a bunch of
reports that I've looked at which
estimate that anywhere between 40 and 60
percent of current jobs would be subject
to partial or full automation a lot of
those jobs are what I guess we would
call white-collar jobs or information
jobs so what is your assessment of the
truth about what the class impact will
be of this well again quite a student
observation David and in comment over
the I think it's not well known that
since about 2000 the demand for skill in
the United States has actually declined
okay now that's a hard thing to get your
head around because what we're told is
we need more and more education to be
competitive that more and more of us
need to graduate from college or
graduate school but in fact the demand
for skill has actually declined since
2000 it increased before that time and
therefore more and more education and
specialized training was was effective
before that but since 2000 not so much
and it's because of what you're
describing the middle skill jobs have
been hollowed out to a great degree and
meanwhile I spoke to oh my god dozens of
computer scientists who told me that the
kind of jobs that are most desired to be
automated are the most skilled jobs
right those are the highest paying jobs
those are the kinds of jobs that
employers what
love to see automated if they could be
automated let me give you an example
there are machines that can flip
hamburgers right now right
but fast-food outlets are not
necessarily buying those machines
because they can pay people very little
to flip hamburgers right so they don't
want to buy machines and machines are
more expensive than the people and so
why bother but if you can automate a
highly sophisticated financial advisors
job or a physicians job or a lawyer's
job the payoff is enormous so there's a
tremendous rush to see how those
particular jobs can be automated so I
think it's really naive to think that
it's only low-skilled jobs that are
becoming digitalized those were the
easiest ones to do and of course many of
them have been but the focus now is
going up the pay scale and going up the
skill scale so this is going to be kind
of a less class-based than you may think
many people are concerned about this and
are preparing for this and Millennials
and Generation Z you know people under
you know age twenty eight twenty five
are finding themselves in many cases
underemployed even though they have
college degrees they're finding that
they cannot find positions commiserate
with their education so this is
something you know we need to deal with
an effective way and something again
that we have to face rather than telling
everyone they need more and more
education and more and more skills we
have to sit back and think okay what
kind of skills what kind of education
and what kind of jobs the book is
fantastic it's called the job work and
it's future and a time of radical change
it really ties together a lot of the
topics we've been talking about on the
program for a long time we've been
speaking with the book's author Ellen
rupal shell who is also a correspondent
for the Atlantic Ellen really a pleasure
speaking to you today thank you so much
David it was a real pleasure